And in terms of narratives and
stories, do you have any examples of a visualization where you think this was
a great story, this told a really amazing story?
>> Yeah, one that struck me relatively recently is
the slope graph that's on the cover of Alberto Cairo's book.
So here what we've got plotted is,
on the left hand side, the percent of higher educated population by state.
And then on the right hand side, the percent obese again by state.
And then a given state's connected by the line.
Which allows you to see relatively quickly the sort of inverse relationship here
across the blue states you know, positive relationship here in the red states.
And can allow you to really in a straightforward manner without really having to
explain too much about it get an understanding and
pick out interesting things, and again, start to form that story or narrative.
This was the, actually, the first time I encountered a slope graph, or
at least the first time that one stuck with me.
And I found it inspiring because there are actually a lot of
different use cases for graphs like this.
Which I hadn't really anticipated.
because you're really only plotting two data points, right?
>> Really. Yeah.
>> One way is you know, to look at things over time, and again,
with only two data points you think that's not that interesting.
But depending on your data it can be.
Or also the comparison of groups.
so, for example here in this little graph,
I'm plotting feedback from employees' survey.
Where on the left hand side, we have the percent favorable you know,
a summary metric for the survey for the overall company.
And on the right hand side, for a given team.
This can be your engineering organization, for example.
And you can see really quickly a whole lot of things, right?
>> Right. >> So, on the left hand side you get the absolute values,
you get the relative rank ordering of the different dimensions.
You get those things on the right hand side as well.
And then via the slope of the lines here, you get the percent difference between
the groups without ever having to explain what a percent difference is.
So it's just a really efficient form of communication for
the right circumstance.
>> Yeah, that's great.
When I look at this graph, one of my key takeaways is this.